this is a very interesting question this
notion of how analytical our sense of
smell is you might say and there's some
some classic work done by phoning David
lang in Australia in which he showed
that if he takes four odors let's say
four fairly common odors that you would
have no trouble identifying puts them in
little bottles the fluids little bottles
one after another puts them under your
nose you say oh that's banana that's
lavender whatever the four are and then
he blends them together in ways and he
doesn't tell you what he so he puts two
of them together and puts it under your
nose and you can identify quite easily
which two he's put in in any random way
then he puts three of them together and
it becomes much more difficult to figure
out which three of the four are in there
and by the time he puts four in there
there's no way you know so actually the
experiments done with six so you know
otherwise you'd know it was just the
four so that once you hit three or four
odors in a blend you have a great deal
of difficulty analytically determining
what are the things that made up that
now essentially new perception of a
particular odor of the blend and that's
true not only as it turns out for
amateurs but normal people but also for
perfumers and well trained chefs in and
fragrance artists